alex is with us in Dallas hey Alex how
are you great day thanks for taking my
call I hate investing question so we're
currently on baby steps four five and
six and we recently and just changed
over our 401k provider at work so I'm
doing enough to get the match at work
and then we have two Roth are raised
outside with a financial advisor perfect
in looking at the fund lifetime
performance and the expense ratios the
401k investments seem to be
outperforming the Roth IRA investments
would it ever make sense to quit doing
one of the Ross in front more into my
401k investment to save that cells
charged I'm getting hit with every month
it's possible what would be wrong with
just moving into those funds that you're
in in the 401 K we know I'm already into
them so instead of doing them the exact
same if your funds at the 401 K are
outperforming the funds that you have in
the Roth why not just buy the ones from
the 401 K in the wrong well I would I'm
currently in all of them but I would
invest more into the Roth 401 K than the
wrong not you're not understanding me
you're in fund a B and C in the 401 K
and you told me it's out performing
funds x y&z in your Roth correct Roth
IRA and Roth 401 K right mm-hmm but your
401k funds the particular mutual funds
that you're in in your 401 K are
outperforming the particular funds that
you're in there are different funds in
your Roth IRA correct yes sir why not
buy the same funds from your 401 K in
your Roth IRA I be on the same
performance based on based on the family
of investments that the financial has
advisor has me and they're not available
well yeah he sells every fund okay so he
just had me in this particular yeah you
can move into a different family into
the family you're in over on the 401 get
the you know you know just use an
example I mean let's say you're in I
don't know fidelity Magellan it in your
401 K I'm a
get up one well you can buy fidelity
Magellan over in your Roth IRA through
your broker if you want to there's no
reason to not do that and the expense
ratios and everything ought to be about
the same there shouldn't be any big
difference unless there's something
unusual about the way something
structured but I mean if you're
structuring them apples-to-apples a
shares to hay shares or C shares to C
shares with the same exact fund in a
Roth IRA purchase to a broker as you
have through a 401k it ought to be
identical I don't know why wouldn't be
and so if you you know what we're saying
is you're confusing that the the fact
that the Roth IRA somehow is
underperforming the 401k and that's not
the case the funds that you're in in
your Roth IRA are underperforming the
funds that you're in in the 401k so pick
different funds and either roll them
over or just stop and start new ones
next year either way but no I'm gonna
I'm gonna keep non-matching out first in
the Roth IRA because I've got a lot more
control over at long-term with your
financial advisor that's what I'm going
to stay with by the way it sounds like
you're doing a great job overall you're
on top of it and you're managing it and
so forth be careful to not let the
discussion of costs become this big
thing in front of you and keep you from
seeing returns what you're looking for a
returns net of expenses and people get
they get all worried about expenses and
they take a substandard return because
they can get cheaper expenses and their
net after expenses is lower because
they're majoring on the wrong thing you
major on returns you minor on expenses
and what you're looking for is the net
after expenses as your real apples to
apples comparison and that way if you're
doing that you can compare no load with
load you can compare a share to B share
to C share you can do whatever you want
to do then and you can work your way
through it and it's it's very possible
to do an apples to apples comparison but
people get caught up in some the
philosophy if somebody who wrote an
article about know loads who doesn't
know how to actually do the math because
when you actually do the math some know
loads with their expense ratio
have a much lower rate of return because
their maintenance fees are so stinkin
high then a loaded fund with commissions
in other words Commission fund does not
always mean cheap more expensive than
non-commissioned to fund load versus no
load discussion so that's not really
what you're talking about here but
overall I'm saying you know you brought
up expense ratio be careful to not let
that be your primary determining factor
because you can you know you can step
over dollar bills picking up nickels if
you're not careful mathematically but
overall I would try to just get in
better funds within your Roth IRA is
what it sounds like you need to do so
good question man's way stay on top of
it you're gonna have some money that's
all that's excellent
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show say you have to break the cycle
you have to flip this thing on its head
and make it behave you've got to get so
fired up and wired up that you're broke
friends think you've lost your mind